bon on va essayer de faire la lumière là
dessus avec nous sylvie de bellefeuille
qui est avocate chez option
consommateurs bonsoir dame de
bellefeuille alors option consommateurs
sur pause à la réforme du projet de loi
34 qui dans le projet de loi 34 sites
nous pourquoi
il ya plusieurs éléments d'une part le
fameux tran le fameux 500 millions qui
qui doit de redonner sourire les
factures les fonds de crédit de factures
en fait c'est pas de l'argent nouveau
c'est de l'argent qui hydro québec doit
déjà remettre aux consommateurs ils sont
avait conservé le processus de fixation
des tarifs
sarr été pris en compte lors de la
prochaine fixation d'observer un effet à
la baisse sur les tarifs
alors c'est pas de l'argent nouveau
c'est juste la présentation de cet
argent lucky qui fait en sorte que quand
on parle beaucoup de ce chef là mais
au-delà de ça il ya aussi plusieurs
pouvoirs de la régie de l'énergie qui
sont retirés par ce projet de loi là
c'est encore plus inquiétant pour les
consommateurs répondent l'ensemble la
clientèle d'hydro-québec mais le
gouvernement dit on un peuple de là on
amène de la prévisibilité quand on
regarde et on va le présenter à l'écran
les ce qui est prévu dans le projet de
loi 34 cette remise 500 dollars le gel
tarifaire et la hausse également en
fonction de l'inflation de 2021 à 24
est-ce que j'ai pas un portrait clair de
ce qui va se passer d'ici 2024 avec ça
ou pas pas que ça parce que à moins
d'avoir une boule de cristal on peut pas
savoir quel jour on est quel va être
l'inflation pour les prochaines années
dont il ya quand même cet élément là
qu'on doit tenir compte et quand on
regarde l'eau depuis les douze dernières
années à part à deux occasions les faits
les hausses de tarifs qui ont été
accordées par la région est inférieur au
taux de l'inflation
donc c'est pas clair que si on continue
de cette façon là les tarifs
d'hydro-québec vont remonter aussi vite
que l'inflation
mais dans la mesure où le gouvernement a
des projets et ça ça fait ça fait un
impact bien sûr sur les tarifs quand
gouvernement à des projets de production
il peut y avoir un impact à la hausse
sur les tarifs
si on le fixe à l'inflation est ce qu'on
vient pas se protéger de hausse
tarifaire de 3 4% comme on a pu
connaître certaines zones et les années
où il y avait des plus autres
documentaires les plus grande
augmentation tarifs c'est est due
principalement aux approvisionnements
post patrimoniaux ce à dire qu'on devait
hydro québec devait h
l'énergie qui est produite par les
éoliennes par exemple maintenant cette
partie elle est stabilisée on prévoit
pas que des agences d achat
supplémentaire qui serait à la hausse
même au contraire on voit avec
l'augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie allait puiser dans le trou
dans le beignet rejet en trop qu'on a
normalement que vous rapport que ça a
c'est un pas qu'ils allaient même
jusqu'à dire qu'on va payer plus cher
probablement oui effectivement nous
c'est ça qu'on a c'est notre prétention
on pense que compte tenu de l'évolution
du marché présentement on ne prévoit pas
que le taux d'augmentation serait aussi
élevé que le taux d'inflation est ce qu
on comprend que la notion de trop-perçus
va disparaître ou en tout cas va
s'évanouir avec ce projet de loi
ben effectivement parce qu'en faisant ça
la régie lorsqu'elles fixent les tarifs
elle permet à hydro québec de faire un
certain montant de profits 6/8 aux
tarifs parce que une évaluation mal
évalué les dépenses par exemple si tour
des projections si un trop perçu qui est
fait par hydro québec mais à ce moment
là dans l'année suivante la régie
l'énergie vont tenir compte de ce trop
perçu l'oeil ça va avoir un impact à la
baisse sur les tarifs l'année suivante
donc il ya déjà un processus qui est
fait pour éviter ce genre de trop perçu
là ce qui s'est passé au gouvernement
précédent quand on a mis en place ce
système là bas le gouvernement à
l'époque avait choisit plutôt de
suspendre l'application de cette partie
là il y avait choisi conserver les
profits est ce qu'avec la nouvelle façon
de faire
au lieu d'aller devant la régie de
l'énergie à tous les ans pour établir
les cours qui est la fixation des prix
laure savasta tous les cinq ans est-ce
qu'on va être capable d'identifier dans
les cinq dernières années
la partie qui est trop perçu sariska la
difficile parce que c'est tout le
problème c'est quand on fait nous
demande quand hydro québec afin de
demander à ses employés le doigt bref
que ça semblait pardon fixa centaines
d'oiseaux québec doit déposer toute une
série de climat des documents comptables
et tout ça pour pouvoir justement
justifier cette hausse aucune preuve qui
est quand même assez assez lourde que
doit faire hydro québec qui doit être
contrebalancé par des experts en faisant
la demande seulement tous les cinq ans
oui hydro québec voit remettre d etat
finance
aimé qu'ils vont être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus large à chaque année va
être déposée seulement une seule fois
aux cinq ans qui doit être celle de
faire le suivi effectivement les profits
d'hydro-québec
les bénéfices vont au gouvernement il ya
un dividende qui est versé au
gouvernement donc en principe si les
dividendes d'hydro québec augmente le
gouvernement pas des sommes
supplémentaires à investir en éducation
et en santé
vous me voyez venir avec ma question est
ce que dans le fond là enfin un débat à
savoir si on veut plus ou moins de
tarifs d'électricité mais au bout de la
ligne c'est quand même pour investir
dans l'état québécois et dans nos
services publics
le problème c'est que ça survienne une
forme de taxation indirecte et qui ne
tient pas compte de la capacité de payer
des gens normalement l'impôt c'est
calculé en fonction de vos revenus aux
niveaux même chose quand vous achetez
des biens vous allez acheter des biens
en fonction de vos revenus pour ce que
l'électricité les conservateurs ont pas
vraiment de contrôle à ce niveau là les
des ménages à faible revenu qui doivent
payer des factures très très élevé parce
que leur logement et mal ma guise au
lait par exemple ces gens là vont devoir
absorber ces semble alors que si on
ad'autres tout de taxation qui tienne
compte des revenus en europe à cet
impact lourd pour les ménages à faibles
peuvent donc vous demander le retrait du
projet de loi
absolument et une refonte quand même une
révision du travail de la régie
d'énergie ou le maintient le statu quo
mais il ya effectivement des choses la
régie on pourrait peut-être améliorer
des choses hydro québec doit notamment
que ça coûte à charge pour ces processus
là est-ce qu'il faut revoir les
processus pour alléger
peut-être l'air sont en hausse pour ce
que nous ont ce qu'on propose c'est
qu'on revoie de façon plus globale
l'euro/dollar yjc des moyens d'alléger
cette preuve la foule
sylvie de bellefeuille avocate chez
option consommateurs merci beaucoup
merci avec nos services